الرؤيه في تويتر ضبابيه هل ينهار تويتر او
يفلس سؤال يتردد على لسان الجميع بعد
الفوضى العامه التي ضربت المنصه منذ ان
باتت في عهده الون ماسك
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه تركت السؤال
عينه واعتبرت ان رد فعل ماسك على احدث
موجه فوضى في تويتر كانت مثيره للجدل
وغريبه عندما غرد بصوره قبر وعليها شعار
تويتر هذه الصوره دفعت بالكثيرين الى
التساؤل عما اذا كانت ازمه تويتر وجوديه
بالفعل
ماسك سر حا ما يقرب من نصف القوه العامله
في الموقع والبالغ عددها سبعه الاف 5700
موظفا في الاسبوع الاول من نوفمبر بعد
ايام على توليه مهمه قياده تويتر مما يعني
ان العدد المتبقي من الموظفين اصبح حوالي
ثلاثه الاف و 750 موظفا
وبين ليله وضحاها غادر عدد جديد من
الموظفين بعد ان حدد ماسك لهم موعدا
نهائيا لقبول ساعات طويله من العمل من دون
شروط ووفقا للتقارير اختار
75% انهاء الخدمه وهو ما سيترك اقل من الف
موظف في تويتر هذا الامر سيؤدي الى انهيار
تويتر وفق الجارديان التي اعتبرت انه بعد
مغادره عدد من المهندسين الرئيسيين لتويتر
هناك مخاوف كبيره من ان الموقع سيكون عرضه
للاعطال الفنيه بسبب النظام المعقد الذي
يقوم عليه تويتر
افلاسه شركه تويتر امر وارد ايضا لان
عائدات تويتر السنويه من الاعلانات تمثل
90 في المئه من اجمال الايرادات اي اكثر
من خمسه مليار دولار لكنه
الايرادات قد تضرر بسبب التوقف المؤقت في
الانفاق من قبل العملاء الرئيسيين هذه
الازمه اكدها ماسك بعد ان اعلن عن انخفاض
كبير في عائدات الاعلانات في اعقاب عمليه
الاستحواذ محذرا من انهيار الشركه قائلا
انه من دون زياده في ايرادات الاشتراك قد
لا ننجو من الركود المقبل
محاسن حضاره العربيه